do you think you're good at giving
advice I believe that I'm probably
better at giving advice than taking it
what's the best advice you've ever heard
who don't have a plan B so that way you
a better chance to plan a working how
much should I tip my barber I'm a big
fan of tip generously my grandfather
took me to a Dodger game when I was
about 10 and handed a guy ten dollar
bill for something and I said grandpa
why'd you do that he said well you know
do you want to do it he does and I said
I mean not really any till that's even
more the reason why you should - so tip
your barber a lot at least 20% I'm going
on vacation with my girlfriend's family
they're big into cycling and keep
talking about how we're all going to go
on lots of long bike rides
only problem is I can barely ride a bike
how can I get out of going with them
without seeming weird learn how to ride
a bike men I mean right just it's a
basic thing man some people just need
some help I started using tinder after
me and my last girlfriend broke up I've
matched with a few people but have no
idea what to say to any of them to get
the conversation going what's a good
non-creepy opening line I would say just
don't be on tinder and like go to a bar
or do something else go out there into
the world it's much more challenging to
go and talk to somebody in person really
because tinder is for like weird sleazy
late now huh cups anyway right I
wouldn't know that but it's over here
you